[Music]
imagine lowering yourself into the Earth
the people around you supporting you
[Music]
two have a beautiful family thank you
okay is that you
[Music]
I'm here for every visit
he doesn't want to go your children
needs stability and at the moment we
haven't seen enough what more do you
need to see
[Music]
to start speaking up in class
whoever helped anybody with an open
adoption
they try to take our culture try to take
our freedom
and you know they'll try to take our
babies too
that's exactly why we can't stop
fighting for our kids G
foreign
[Music]
I don't want my kids going through what
I've been through we don't have to do
this if it doesn't feel right
I'm committed to my kids
no matter what
always be their mama
thanks
[Music]